[Music]
could plant-based vaccines save the
world
scientists say rice
corn potatoes or lettuce can be used to
produce antibodies
it's a kind of complex process which
starts by
the procedure that infects them with a
foreign
dna
genetic material that reprograms them to
stop doing everything else and just make
one
protein recombinant protein which is a
medicine that we want to produce
biotech firms are already in clinical
trials with their plant-based drugs or
awaiting approval from health agencies
to combat ebola the norovirus and covet
19.
i'm ben fazoulen this isn't just about
pleasing vegans a plant-based covert jab
would be cheaper and quicker and instead
of using hamster ovaries or monkey
kidneys you can use veggies or even
tobacco
the plants being grown inside this
greenhouse could form the basis of a new
covid19 vaccine
the nicotiana benthamiana to give it its
proper name is currently the focus of a
study by canadian biotechnology company
medicargo and britain's glaxosmithkline
20 000 people are taking part in the
trial
it's the first time a plant-based
vaccine is being developed you introduce
the dna which triggers the production of
a spike protein very similar to the
coronavirus but which isn't infectious
when you remove it from the plant put it
in the vaccine and add an adjuvant
a substance that boosts the body's
immune response the vaccine can generate
more antibodies
preliminary results suggest the
plant-based vaccine may produce up to 50
times more antibodies than other jabs
gizelle clark is among 7 000 argentinian
participants in the trial
she works as a journalist and has
written extensively about covid19
vaccines
now she wants to learn more about
production methods herself
[Music]
vegetarians and vegans are especially
interested in the idea of a plant-based
vaccine
while no other covid19 jab is of animal
origin either this particular trial has
attracted many vegan and vegetarian test
subjects in argentina
the country with its rich livestock
tradition is the second largest beef
consumer per capita worldwide but the
number of vegetarians and vegans is
growing
they now make up over 10 of the
population
linking meat consumption to
environmental issues
anything that bans animals from our
plates is very controversial in
argentina due to our traditions and
deeply ingrained habits
but every day people are becoming more
environmentally aware
against this backdrop a plant-based
vaccine even one which is being tested
on animals has already piqued the
interest of many people
[Music]
i asked zachary leblanc from queensland
university of technology why animals are
still used to make
vaccines hey ben well that's uh it's an
interesting question um
mainly
when you say animals uh typically what's
used for vaccine manufacturers are
actually animal cells so at that point i
wouldn't quite call it an animal because
it's not an organism at that point it's
just a cell in culture that's being used
to produce these vaccines which are
complex
proteins
so
i wouldn't quite say that animals are
being harmed in the process
but the advantage of using plants is
that it's really in the scalability of
the system versus these other
mammalian cell based systems
and why is it cheaper
so it's cheaper
because of the scalability essentially
um if you think about the inputs that
you need for growing a plant right you
need to put it you need to give it water
you need to give it sunlight and you
need to give it dirt
you compare those inputs to a lot of
these other systems which are
fermenters that are used to culture
large amounts of mammalian cells and it
becomes it's visibly a lot cheaper when
you're producing a plant to amplify this
biomass which can then produce your
vaccine
i was also reading that there's no need
for bioreactors in some cases no
purification process so i guess you're
cutting a lot of costs there and
does that make it then safer all in all
so um
in in terms of safety yeah because if if
you think about uh pathogens that act on
mammalian cells if you're producing
um your vaccine mammalian cell it's
there is a possibility of a pathogen
getting that can affect that mammalian
cell also affecting the end user now if
you're using a plant um they don't share
a lot of they don't share any pathogens
with humans so you're not going to have
a pathogen that's going to attack your
your cultures that would then attack the
end user so in that sense it's more safe
and to answer the bit about bioreactors
actually um
when you're using plants as a production
system the plant itself is the
bioreactor so that that sort of feeds
into why they're more cost effective as
a production platform
so the million-dollar question for you
zach how much quicker would we have
immunized the world if we'd had a
plant-based covert vaccine considering
they're quicker cheaper and safer
yeah um
i'd say it's a
yeah nearly a billion dollar crush
question when you're talking about covet
vaccines but um
uh i don't think much would change to be
honest um
because the the hurdle is really getting
through those clinical trials um and for
production of a coded vaccine i mean
there's a group in north america called
medicago that's in phase three clinical
trials for production of a covid19
vaccine
and
after receiving the sequence for the
spike protein um they were able to
produce a vaccine within 20 days so they
had it on hand it's just that you need
all that time to make sure it's safe to
uh distribute to the general population
and that's why those lengthy clinical
trials are there
so will we get one
during this pandemic or or are we going
to have to wait some years until we see
a plant-based
vaccine for for whatever the disease may
be
oh yeah well i mean let's see how long
the pandemic lasts right um
but uh
i i would say
there's there's some promising
candidates that are being produced by
medical in north america um they have
a covid19 vaccine which is in phase
three clinical trials which
means i mean it it's
i would expect uh an announcement about
that sometime this year i think but um
who knows how how long these things take
they also have another
vaccine quadrivalent flu vaccine that
they have in production which is also in
phase three clinical trials so i think
it's a really exciting time and i i
think it's it's likely that we'll be
seeing a plant-based vaccine in the near
future yeah
just briefly as well can can you
eliminate the need for uh animal testing
for these vaccines uh so that the
process is 100 vegan
uh so i don't know about that part um
because uh when you're going to clinical
trials you're putting this vaccine into
human participants in the trial and
before that step you want to really test
it on a living system so you can be sure
that it's safe before it's going in in a
real life person's arm
so
i don't see a pathway towards
eliminating the use of animals
maybe sometime in the future when you
can
properly mimic those systems but at this
point no i don't think we can eliminate
animals from the process
zachary leblanc from qut queensland
university of technology in brisbane
australia thank you very much for being
on the show
well thanks for having me take care ben
now here's an interesting question on
the delta variant but i'll let derek
williams answer that for you
what makes people with the delta variant
so much more contagious
in trying to answer this i think that we
first need to go back to a term that
once got a lot of air time but that many
of you have probably since forgotten and
and that's the basic reproduction number
of a pathogen or it's are not now the r
naught describes the average number of
people that an infected person will
infect in turn
in an unexposed unvaccinated population
when it first hit
the ancestral coronavirus had an r
naught of around two to three so
each infected person on average infected
two to three others
but the original virus has since mutated
into a range of variants among them the
delta variant and and it's a lot more
transmissible with an r naught
that's estimated to be twice as high or
or maybe even higher
of course
a lot more people are now largely immune
to the virus due to vaccination or
previous infection so
each new delta patient isn't actually
infecting twice as many others but still
people who get the delta variant are a
lot more contagious than those who have
other variants of the virus
so what exactly has raised the r naught
in the delta variant well
researchers think that two changes in
particular are probably behind its
increased transmissibility the first
involves a set of mutations that they
say have altered the structure of the
spikes
that dot the outer surface of the virus
the spikes are what allow the virus to
latch on to receptors
on a cell's outer membrane and break
into it and and scientists believe that
changes to the delta variant spikes have
made that break in process easier
the second change involves how much of
the virus is being produced by cells
one study found
that delta variant patients had viral
loads that were around a thousand times
higher than what's found in those
infected with the original virus
with that massive replication also
possibly happening a lot faster
all of those factors scientists think
are contributors to making the delta
variant one of the most infectious
respiratory diseases out there
[Music]
see you next time